[Music]
so
we have
one apology from mark
brown
somebody move that we accept that
apology please
can you hear me
yes nikki moved
well i'll move that we accept the
apology for mark brown may have a second
day
i will
doug would you like us to to speak to
unmute or shall we just raise our hands
can you see us okay well enough to do
that
sorry what was that
um we usually just raise hands in a zoom
meeting would you like us to just raise
our hands or would you like us to unmute
uh you can raise your hand to
who's going to be the secular that's me
that's you right all in favor
against
carrie thank you
right no public forum
conflicts of interest
no conflicts of interest
confirmation the minutes
from
the minutes of the officer hokey
community board on the second of march
to 2020
um
one thing i'd like to say before we
confirm that was that sarah barca was in
prison was present although she's not in
the list
but with that added in somebody move
that those minutes be re signed as a
true record please thank you shirley
second up
wendy thank you
all in favor
against
terry thank you
measures horizon
julie
unmute chili
can you hear me now yeah
um i just want to ask if there's been
any
more information regarding the ev
stations in oxford remember
uh the council staff are going to go
back to the farmers market
about the 24 7 time
for it to be
open so just wondering if anybody has
heard anything
yep
your name sorry yeah you're all good i
answer the most things doug it's not a
problem um
actually yesterday
i know she has been in touchnets and it
was from her perspective like totally
fine but i haven't just heard back
exactly formally um what's been you know
agreed but i understand that she'd been
in contact there were no issues but i
will just follow up and get her perhaps
flip us away email is that all right
yep thank you
any other matters
charlie
can you hear me now
yeah
i'd just like to bring you up to speed
with uh regarding the speed limits in
the letter from that ted drink actually
got
i met with uh councillor gordon and we
zoomed into
joanne
what did concern me that
a report was going to go out to the
board and that the
staff hadn't even
talked to waka
katahi
about ted's letter
so um i actually contacted the man who
wrote the letter and he said everything
there was correct
um and he was going to contact the guy
who the roading engineers had
contacted regarding the speed limit
review
and
chris
rodley came back to me and said that was
was correct what was in the letter so to
cut us long story short um
councillor gordon
actually was going to organize a zoom
meeting with the two people from the
wakata katahi
and
joanne himself
and some other people to find out what
the difference is he was going to try
and do that within two weeks it's been
over two weeks i haven't heard but no
doubt we'll hear you in due course but
attached to the report that was going to
go to the board
i suggested that it didn't go until they
actually talked to aldmyn said
was it was going to cost
469 thousand dollars
um they'd done a spreadsheet on it so
that really concerned me
thank you
thank you surely
crazy you got nothing to comment there
oh okay thank you
any further matters arising
yeah i've got something done
yeah no thomas
ah thank you um just wondering if we had
an update on the situation in mandeville
with the asbestos
outside the manual sports club
we have to ask the green space team
there's one of them here
i i don't have the information to be
able to give you an update myself um but
i can certainly um put that request to
grant mcleod when i get into the office
tomorrow
you gotta be great thanks
thank you
can i just add
um
at the moment that um
basically that that sits with the
mandeville
sports club
and um they are looking into um
legal issues etc so um
basically that's sitting with them at
the moment and um
i guess well here in due course but the
council has done everything that they
can to make it safe and from there it's
it's more process so i don't know if
that helps but um everything is fairly
public excluded so
yeah
thank you
anything else
all right
so
can somebody move those minutes baseline
is a true record please
right thank you
wendy second thank you forum favor
against
jarrett thank you
no deputations and presentations
know you're in business
report on general landscaping budget
grant stevens thank you right
good evening thank you for having me
here um today with you um
yeah so
it's that time of the year again where
i've got the report up for you
for the general landscaping um budget so
um you might remember
i think it was november last year i came
and did a workshop um with the board and
i do apologize for not getting this
report back to you earlier it
has been one of those things which
um it has been a bit of work but has
also been at the mercy of we've had a
few staff changes in our green space
team and um our capacity is
significantly lowered at the moment
while we look for another landscape
architect um to fill kevin dwyer's role
since he left so um that being said the
report is here and and hopefully um
tonight you might be able to allocate
some budget towards um the projects that
you you were looking at so
um i'll take it that you've read the
report so i won't um it's quite a long
report so i won't read for it all um
i'll just i guess skip over pretty much
um from that report um as staff we've
recommended the allocation of budget to
i guess a range of projects across the
district um
so across your your ward i guess in in
in that area um so we have um
recommending three thousand dollars to
the oxford so to your hoka domain flying
fox um that that is nearly um it's kind
of on the cusp of completion and they
just need a bit more to get across the
line um
the
residents association have done an
amazing job um and pushing that and
driving it and getting there so it would
be great to see that finished and kids
being able to
enjoy that
we have um
3500 to purchasing and installing a
picnic table within swananoa domain
so that came out of the suggestion of
there was a landscape plan done
a number of years back for swan and i
domain and a few different
landscape features identified on that um
two of them that uh highlighted a report
the picnic table or the tree planting um
are there we've suggested based i i
guess
um on just what's in your budget and
what you can kind of tick off um well
and truly within this financial year the
the option one the picnic table um and
and that will also get great bang for
its buck of people being able to sit and
enjoy and
um enjoy that that domain um we also
have um fifteen hundred dollars towards
landscaping around the rodeo shed at
mandeville domain um so
that that's still progressing um the the
erection of that shed on site but um
they would like a bit of help or support
to do some planting around it much like
what the board has previously done for
projects such as like the
ohoka gatekeepers lodge
um
we have the oxford cemetery wildflowers
um 1500 towards um
getting some wildflower seeds and
sprinkling them over
what we've identified as um potential or
likely unmarked graves in the area to
the south of the i guess what's
currently understood as um full cemetery
that whole space is cemetery allocated
land um but um the area you're between
what's i guess the fenced off symmetry
and the reserve um you're planting some
wildflower seeds in there um
then
um
a small allocation of 350 towards the
oxford community gardens um they're just
wanting some support to
um help grow plant and grow some bee
friendly plants love um
i think in in the words of their
coordinator they're sick of trying to
pull um vegetables out of public toilets
um and instead would like to um have the
people who are stealing the vegetables
get stung by bees
so um not quite like that but they are
keen to to do some bee friendly plants
um we see bee friendly plants is great
for our biodiversity in our environment
and people being able to it still has
that learning function where people can
learn about um
plants you can put put in a vegetable
garden to encourage pollination and
things like that so it still fits in
with the i guess that community garden
theme and finally 3 000 towards the
manville village reserve picnic tables
so
um you might remember
two years ago i think it was the board
allocated 500 towards the allocation of
those picnic tables
um on the uh the understanding the
residents association we're going to
um
we were pretty much putting the the cost
of the the concrete or materials to do
so and they were going to undertake the
work
um we've been in a discussion with james
ensor who was kind of leading that
project at the time and
um that's i i guess that has stalled um
and
um
it's we we don't see it progressing
anytime soon um so
felt that if that's if the board do want
to see them brought out into the reserve
as per their plan
um the best way forward probably would
be to get a contractor to do so in which
case obviously we have to pay um what
current market rate is for concrete and
installation so um that's where so
that's for both picnic tables um
where that leaves two projects i guess
that were previously discussed
on on the table for future
considerations so
one of them is the pump track um
down at mandeville domain so they just
that just needs a bit more work
um between those who
are keen and interested for that project
and the amanda will domain
um medical sports club who look after
that domain and i guess building that
that concept and an idea and then that
could
either come back to the board um if it's
i guess with it within your budget
ability for um allocation or it may form
part of a future annual plan um or
long-term plan bid depending on how that
i guess builds or
transpires um
and the the final one being west eaton
um train platform heritage so
the board had a
um
deputation by tim fulton um
regarding the protection of of the
previous west yetin um train station
opposite western hall um
i've been to being down on site i've
been um had quite a few talks with with
him and he's he's a raft of information
and we've also um dragged bernard
kingsbury um from the cusp museum into
into the fray as well and and he's been
helping us um provide us with some
sketches of how that that whole thing
was laid out
it's quite a complex one because
obviously there's not a lot of room
between
these
structures and and the actual north ear
road so we need to make sure that
whatever we're proposing is safe
um we're not introducing a risk and we
also need to make sure that what we're
doing is
um
for example the mound one of the the
early suggestions was could we put a
sort of post and rail fence around
much like what is around
the
oaks domain um or oak domain i should
say opposite west denton hall um
but that
um opposes health and safety in terms of
the road corridor but issues but also
would mean that you kind of wouldn't see
the mound at all anyway so
part of i guess protecting a heritage
feature is also
um enabling people to be able to see it
and appreciate it for what it is so
um we're recommending that that gets
left on the table um tim and bernard are
keen to continue working with us with a
green space um
to try and come up with an appropriate
way and we will tie in with the roading
team as well on that um and hopefully be
able to present something back to the
board once that's um i guess a bit more
clear on what we can and can't do and
what those costs might be associated
with that
um
that's pretty much what's in the report
so um happy to take any um any questions
you might have
yeah thank you
thank you unmute
oh yes grant um just a quick question
about the um
underground radar that was performed in
oxford at the cemetery there um
the unmarked graves that have been
found are they going to be designated in
any way or it is the intention just to
oversold the whole area with the wild
flowers
yes so um the intention was to i guess
over so that that whole area so um
kind of creates i guess garden beds of
wildflowers that
um go over the the particular areas so
um
and i think i hopefully i included a
yeah i included a bit of a plan in that
report um for you so there's sort of the
purple on page 21 of your agenda the the
purple kidneys is probably the best way
to describe them um
yeah so
at this point
we don't we didn't want to i guess
um put a stake in the ground on on each
um
each site as an and put kind of a marker
someone is buried here um we don't
frankly we don't know who
who is there um we also whilst the um
ground penetration radar has suggested
this
um looks very much like what a grave
like this would look like um so so they
look at depth they look at size they
look at whether it's the ground has been
disturbed between whatever's under there
and the top
um we can't handle heart say that's most
certainly a coffin without or or a grave
without actually digging it up and
that's certainly not something that
we're um
recommending we go down that track on um
so it was more a case of
i guess providing something
um which brings a bit of beauty to that
space for whoever is interred under
there um it's a bit of a reminder but it
also
um i guess brings a bit of color and an
opportunity for people in the in the
wider reserve but also in the cemetery
to to go and potentially pick some
flowers and put them on on their loved
ones grave or so it sort of ties the two
together um but you know we weren't at
this point
um looking at marking each one
and uh the future of any dog park in
oxford um
uh that's not mentioned anywhere but is
that still on the uh on the cards
yes so the damn
the board were successful in your um
submission to the long long term plan
for a dog park or i think it ended up
being called a rural town dog exercise
area or something like that um
so so budget was allocated for that i
believe it was in year three of the long
term plan um so
planning for that will start with our
team probably next
um in sort of 20 i think the budget
comes available in 2024 so um we'll be
looking 2023 to start designing that
don't quote me on those those dates but
it but it is um it wasn't in those first
couple of years of the long term
um
that's
that is for um
the area i guess to the
so
south of here you've got
the oaks reserve with a big stand of oak
trees and then
south of that you then have that the
field
um
which goes between those oaks and the
cycon yard
um so the the dog park is planned for
in that space so um this this space
we wouldn't intend there would be
um people
using utilizing it as a dog dog park
area
um this i guess also
um this whole area is allocated as
future symmetry so in time
um defense between it and the cemetery
will will no longer i guess be be
required um
and and there will be
um
i guess that will be moved back we have
a bylaw that prevents dogs from going
into into symmetries so um that the area
as as that cemetery grows um
that area will
[Music]
become part of that um as part of that
also i should mention um
on our green space work plan is to
um do a bit of a design for the
that space um so that when we
um when we go up because it each year we
have budget goes towards um putting in
new booms so that when when they require
that they're ready and there um so we're
we're creating a bit of a plan for that
which we will bring to the board um
that
shows where those um berms would be and
any implication of those unmarked graves
on those berms um so obviously we want
to be careful that if we're allocating a
plot to someone that's that plot isn't
already in use i guess so um
that that's something that we're
intending on designing in the next
financial year so
um we'll hopefully be coming to the
board
sometime late in this calendar year or
early
i next think she's gone
thank you grant uh any further questions
for grant
i think surely does
uh you're amazing clearly
sorry
um just a couple of things to let the
board know what one that keep ups are
beautiful are actually have planned a
bulb
um
planting thing on this weekend um it's
actually advertised from the bulletin so
i could actually send that to you if
anyone's interested um and also if we do
agree to these um things today i'm just
a little bit concerned about the word
um rodeo
um because we normally put it out into
the community on the facebook page what
um things are a lot of people don't like
that is that could that be changed
oh
um
ah that's a that's a good good question
shirley i mean i i guess we are it would
be given as a grant to the rodeo club
they i guess
the club who do it uh are proud of of
their sport and and what they're doing
so i um
yeah it's a that's a
i probably i'm not sure i i couldn't say
if you would get any flack for putting
money towards rodeo um as a particular
thing
um
i guess
i'll leave that to the board
sarah you had a question
sarah
all right any further questions
yeah
unmute um
just have a question this one and our
domain has got that concept plan
um since was it 2014. so i'm just
wondering why
since then there's been no progress on
it
yes so um
that was before my time at council um so
i'm not entirely familiar but what i'm
i'm guessing it has happened is
um
it used to be council policy to go and
make a
concept plan for every single one of our
domains and we treated that as the
our management technique for that
domain or reserve and so the master plan
kind of
it not only had a design of what it
might look like but it also had um rules
of what you could do
within that space and what might happen
in the future and and and
what sort of sports might go on there
and all those kind of rules and stuff
around them um
shortly after that plan would have been
made we shifted to what's referred to as
an omnibus system where
we actually say all neighborhood
reserves will fit under a neighborhood
reserves management plan and so rather
than spending a time um
designing each each reserve we say this
is a neighborhood reserve this is the
function it fits and here are the rules
and things that will fit into it we then
often
if we've got say a hockey domain is a
good example um
if we've got a playground renewal or
some sort of renewal project in there
we'll often look at the wider domain at
that stage and and go okay as this
opportunities for a bit of development
here um
at this that stage but
that shifting across to that different
management technique i guess um
meant that i guess a lot of those
previous plans and and management plans
became obsolete um that's not to say
that they are irrelevant in terms of
um
driving what might happen if there's
like in this situation where the board
says well can we do something at that
swan another domain um but
i don't believe there was necessarily
intention for each one of those plans
that was made
for
it's to be built then and there um that
it was more okay so let's back a plan as
as we progress through time we'll we'll
do annual plan submissions and um
long-term plan submissions for funding
and things so
i'm guessing that's where that has
i guess the transition across is why
that hasn't progressed down there um
as far as i understand there's no budget
allocated
um to the
um in the long term plan to the
development or
implementation of that plan
um as we speak
um but it does
and the likes of this case does provide
some level of guidance for the board and
what you might be able to do for for the
likes of general landscaping projects
okay um and the other question i had was
um
probably more
to release for tear but can we add the
pump track into our annual plans you
know it's sort of
not going to be picked up in the
landscaping
budget
to you mr cheapest are you talking about
your annual plan submission
um
well it's already been submitted
but i'm sure that you can raise it at
the meeting when you address
the council
okay
thanks that was all i had
thanks for your work on it grant's great
thank you sarah anything else anybody
just a quick question by me mr chair
um
grant just further to um
sorry nicky i think you've cut out there
i'm not sure if anyone else can hear
here
no nobody else you froze me
my connection's unstable um
sorry so
is this still fit for purpose if we want
to pick bits out of it because they've
taken down some some big trees that used
to to go around the perimeter of the
swananoa domain
and i'm not really sure what
the reason was for that if they were
just seen as a fall hazard or something
but
um
with all those trees in that plan would
that actually still even allow cricket
to be played there and whatnot
um my
my understanding is that there is still
intention for cricket to be played there
um
even if if there wasn't i guess it is a
um as a reserve it within swanano i
think um
the likes of a picnic table would
certainly be utilized by people visiting
the domain um
the
i guess that was one of the reasons why
we've put the picnic table ahead in
terms of priority of the the ring of
trees because that
um
before we did that we'd want to have a
bit more consultation and discussion
between um the users of that space and
and what they what impact that might
have and what they've found in the past
around trees and things in the domain so
um i don't think that would impact the
picnic table but yeah that sort of
thinking would certainly um in terms of
the
trees yeah i was probably just getting a
little bit ahead of myself because
certainly a picnic table would go down a
treat and wouldn't make too many waves
i'm sure because that's all we're
talking about at this point but i just
meant for in the future but thank you
yeah
um just just to sort of bring you up on
that was the
that's the um
tennis i mean the the cricket club that
have done a lot of work there
and um
they have put a lot of small trees and
shrubs in
along that area and and um
so probably it would be probably if you
need to ask questions probably would be
the cricket club you need to certainly
consult with us thank you
thank you bendy
right
moving on at this point i would like to
just
because it's a little bit irrelevant but
acknowledge
grant reboon who is resigning or has
resigned and will be leaving shortly
um i didn't realize he was commuting
from nelson for 10 years that's pretty
tremendous really
and he's done a great job another 10
years
thank you grant reboot
i'll be happy to pass it on to you tom
tomorrow doug for you
thank you
right somebody like to move a report
receive grant's report and
i guess we've got to um
agree to
each of those
um proposals for
any discussion
no just a
big thank you very much grant for all
the work you've done i really appreciate
it thank you
yes thank you grant
uh all in favor
sorry nikki
no i always just i was just saying in
favor but um if you're going to give me
a second to speak i would just yeah
again like to acknowledge all the work
that's gone into this there's some great
ideas here it goes right across our
entire ward um looks like everybody gets
something and they're all very worthy
projects so well done with um
divvying up our pot of gold for very
worthy um community projects
so um yeah look forward to getting it
all done and
just just in my own little corner of the
world
my children have been waiting for this
flying fox that they've been planning
for about the last 10 years and they'll
look a little bit out of place on it
once they finally get it done but um
yeah i think all of these things look
amazing and i can't wait for our
community to um get to use them so
yeah
thank you
thomas you tell me
no
anybody else
oh all in favor of that motion
again
jerry thank you
thank you everyone have a great evening
thank you graeme
right application of the office of the
healthy community board's discretion
require
the client for play center
through you mr jefferson um
we all know
the club full play center that ward has
given them funding before they are
requesting funding to buy some new bikes
and scooters for their three to five
year olds they've got a new painted
track and they would love the three to
five-year-olds to be able to use
the track
i will take the reporters read and
take any questions if they might be
i have one question yes the money that
they're requesting
must be real cheap bikes and scooters
doesn't seem to to me to be enough
well mr chair as the board you can
decide actually to give them more if you
do believe that that's
not enough but they do actually have a
quote attached
of which bikes they would like on page
33 so
yeah
i'd like to move that we yeah
doug
sorry
sorry question
yep
question um
are they applying to any other um any of
the other community boards and i was
just seeing looking at their what
they've mentioned um that you know with
the various children that have different
age groups from different areas
um have they are they applying for any
other funds anywhere else
they did they applied to the kaiapoi
board for funding for a mud kitchen
um
but the kaiapoi boat actually declined
the funding
right yeah just looking at the
percentage of
people in their area where oxidative was
nine grand you're actually 25 woody and
stefan and kai boy was
happy to hear he was six so as i just
asked is any are they have they gone to
any other board
those percentages don't even really add
up do they no they don't there might be
a bit of an error i know my children in
the past when they were younger went
there and most of the people that went
there were from
um
our sort of area
but um yeah it doesn't seem to be
maybe they've made an error there yeah i
would think that too because um i know
lots of kids from around the hookah
mandeville swaminova area that go to
clarksville play center
well i'm happy to for them to to receive
that money that's because by looking at
the little bikes it's about what it's
going to cost so
i don't know what anyone else feels
okay
well i'll move that we approve the
ground of
however much is there asking for i can't
remember
376.
yeah
if we approve that grant to the football
play center towards cost pursuing bikes
and scooters
[Music]
sorry yes
wendy you're a
and you're you're
right that's all right sorry
this uh zone thing is not easy to get
used to
and against
right karen thank you
ratification of the oxford ohio
community board submission to the
waimeke district council and environment
canterbury draft in your plans
three you minister to your person this
is just the ratification of the
submissions that we made last week
um i did actually email
everybody the final submissions just to
read
and i will take the report as read
i'll move that we
accept that then
i can think in that and thank you very
much for composing that yeah
yeah
okay
in your discussion
i'd just like to thank tiara as well
she's done a really good job it's well
written and yeah well done thank you
yeah totally agree with that
charlie jake have you been given a date
and a time yet for the hearing
i've been given one for
the
uh waimakariri district council's annual
plan and
i can't remember what date it is but
it's to be in oxford
all right all in favor
against
jerry thank you
correspondence
changing green most composting facility
here have you got something to comment
on that one
no
all right
so
the recommendation is that we receive
the information on the change of green
based composting composting facility
somebody move that we accept that
correspondence
thomas thank you second up
charlie thank you all in favor
against
kerry thank you
chairpersons resort report
verbal update on the meeting um
the only meeting i've been to on this
month is to north canterbury
neighbourhood support
the last meeting
the suggestion was that
the manager
was able to increase her hours from 20
to 30 hours a week
because she's gonna cope with
waimakariri hironui and kaikora
um
and it has been agreed that she goes up
to 32 hours a week so that was
good and
she does an exceptionally good job as
manager of north canterbury neighborhood
support
that's it for me on that one
matters for information somebody moved
that we received those matters please on
item 10
[Music]
right
you
check it out
so you're up
all in favor
yes
all right thank you
how did we handle the public exploder
here you leave it to laughter
no you can just because we only
receiving it you can actually do it now
because you will see that um
recommendation b actually states that it
remains public excluded
okay
so we just
accept that
information yes right thank you so i'll
move that we accept that information
somebody second it
thomas
foreign favor
against
thank you
members information exchange
we'll start with you shirley
um nothing really to report i've been
staying close to home
um i just
opec um had the agm officer promotions
head to agm which resulted in a change
of a chairman and secretary and the vice
chairman still has to be
elected
um i would i would like a comment
um probably tracy from you regarding the
resource consent for the signs at fresh
choice oxford
are you able to do that
but slowly unmute button um
so yes note that you've
put that uh email around the board
uh what did you want to know at this
stage i mean it's just it's just been
received and it's in the process of
being managed
i've been processed
what actually happens
so like all resource consent
applications so it's been received so
the team then consider first off uh two
parts but first off is notification
decision so um is it non-notified
doesn't need to be known for that stage
one and then stage two goes on to
processing the application under
whichever notification that is required
so
um the team are working through that
currently
thank you
um just i did a snap send and solve
regarding that um
unsightly miss on the corner of northier
road and tram road
um it does quite concern me that it's
been left as it is so
um hopefully we can get um
something done about that
um i'd just like to update you on the
mural that is uh was proposed for the
public toilets
um it's been a frustrating time actually
um
yeah there was no guidelines no
application form no nothing really
and so it's gone through
and
it has to go to um
mana
whatever um the ewe
to see if we can paint native birds and
native flora on the public toilets
because the council staff had been
advised that in other places of new
zealand who have wanted to paint these
on public toilets they have been refused
so that's really quite interesting so we
might have to go
another way um time and check we can put
course and broom and magpies and
um
possums and stokes and that and i don't
think anybody would worry but it has
been since october i don't know when it
will end so i just want to let you know
the update of that and that's all i've
got to report
thank you shirley ray
um
yes i did attend the zoo meeting of the
mandeville sports uh club
um
not a lot to really report except that
uh most of the meeting uh
revolved around the um asbestos issue
which uh i understand is um pending
litigation so we probably don't need to
uh go down that uh track again
um but um
i've stayed away from the grey power
meeting due to covert and we have had a
close contact with the family so we've
been
self-isolating but i did receive a um a
letter from uh a resident of um
downs uh ahaka meadows
and uh it's signed by 22 of the 23
residents there who are concerned about
a pond which
no longer exists at the entrance to
hoka meadows
i'm pretty sure it does belong to the
drainage uh catchment area
and
is fed by
ditches that run along mandeville
road and then eventually the water from
there goes into the large reservoir on
the corner of uh white's road and tram
road
they're concerned that uh it's become so
overgrown now that um
it's it's not fit for purpose it used to
be quite a landscape feature when the
ahuka meadows
was first developed but uh now it's just
almost completely silted up and
they did present this to council over a
month ago but they haven't received any
reply or recognition that it has been um
uh presented to uh council so i thought
i would present it here i'll scan it and
send you through a copy tier uh tomorrow
and uh it's maybe something where we we
need to have a meeting on site with the
residents and members of uh
council or the um
um drainage advisory group to see what
can be done with this um
uh particular issue
um but apart from that that's that's all
i've got at the stage
right um
[Music]
i'll check up on the high committees
with the drainage staff and find out
whether it is drainage responsibility or
not
i've had a funny feeling that lahoca
meadows
was not included in the ahoka drainage
scheme i could be wrong
i'll check up on it
thank you ray sarah
sorry don't i think we do have a
detailed map which that was uh has been
given to us but i haven't checked that
to see if this part of the drainage
network is included in the uhoka um if
it's not in the ohio i guess it would be
in the silver stream catchment area but
yeah
that would be great if you could look
into that thank you
are you ready sarah
um i had a zoom wag meeting
uh last night they were discussing the
um
the extended hours health
hub that um is supposed to be going in
it's been uh
obviously on the agenda for quite some
time and it has been um stunted in its
progress
it looks like that they are having to go
back through resource consent um to
discuss with neighbouring properties
because
it will be looking outside of um normal
working hours
so consultation needs to go um through
its process with that
um there's some talk of it becoming a
bit of a um
a political agenda rather than a need
and just being done so it'll be
interesting to see how long that takes
to get back on its feet again and keep
going
and the oxford hospital is obviously
closed supposedly temporarily at the
moment due to
staffing shortages
but there is concern that it
could potentially stay closed um if the
district health board doesn't
have pressure to reopen it again so i'm
dan
mia dan gordon and
some other
people involved in the um
in the health
sector uh going to keep um pressure on
for that to be reopened
um it was supposed to be reopened on the
26th of april but there's no talk of it
um of that happening
there is also actually that the whole
concept is involving the mirrors of
sauwan district and hironoe as well
because it affects them too
there
is
um still issues around the two beds at
regular hospital that aren't being
utilized for um
for people for convolescence either
um and
the cold stream
uh covered center has closed so it's
just up to the pharmacies in rangiora
now to um
to give those services
and that was that there
um
does have two questions which i probably
should have brought up earlier um
specifically with grant there i
just wondering if there was any more
updates about the mandible crossroads
um what was happening in that area that
had been um
cleared but not cleared
so kind of cleared into piles but then
the piles left there
if we had any update on that
or if we could uh
see if we can get an update on that
through you mr jefferson no we haven't
but i will follow that up and come back
to the board on that thank you and the
other one was um
at what point in the process is the the
hokie development currently at tracy you
might be able to answer that one
talk about the plan change
yes yes so no change from last meeting
so it's still in train but we are on
track to have a decision-making report
in front of council at their fourth of
may meeting
okay so what is the decision-making
report so that's where council have to
consider whether they will
decline adopt or
notify or approve notification of the
plan change
okay and does that come with
recommendations from staff correct
right
okay and we don't
um
sort of when we don't find any of it out
until it's been through council is that
correct correct
and the team are still working on it so
it's as you can imagine it's quite
complex and needing to be very thorough
so
that will be formed up and be part of
the report to council
okay thank you
you sarah and tracy thomas
thanks doug um
following on from the comment about the
oxford hospital i know the community
trusts uh concerned about it potentially
not reopening and they're pushing hard
for it through their avenues and their
local the local health care service
provider group i forget what it's called
but they'll haven't had the cdhb so
they're definitely pushing for it to be
reopened but
it definitely could be used as the
backdoor route to close it so we're very
aware of that
um
on the
the meeting side of thing there actually
haven't been hasn't been a pearson park
meeting again
and there hasn't been an actually gorge
meeting either again because of covered
um
the only thing i didn't want to ask if
we could get an update on what's
happening with the um
the small forestry box have been cleared
a bit around
the area there's one at um bennett's
there's one at
uh i think it might be points road or
wolf's road one of the ones
down there
um and there's one
uh out to out on tram road as well that
had been cleared recently that are sort
of just
sitting there so because if we get an
update on what's happening with them
because people are definitely aware
because they're on the roadside
um
yeah i don't know how we ask about that
and
potentially whether they the
carlton reserve
what they do with it going forward
whether we need to be involved in it
because it is a community space now with
the oxford pony club using that area
um but other than that it's very quiet
no meetings or anything so yeah that's
it next
all right thank you thomas
tracy you want to follow me on those
questions
i'm sure t has taken note of those and
we'll follow up
yeah okay thank you
all right councillors
who's first
don't both rush at once now
they have it wendy yours first please
okay thank you
um just one or two little information um
pieces there on
the um backflow prevention policy um
which
this is to protect the water
um from the pipes and such like and
anyone
uh using them um to stop being any um
any discretion going back into the
drinking water things so we've just had
to go through it was done in 2014 when
we first adopted it
um and it's just moved
back now um and we've had to redo it
again but under the services the water
services act it came into force we've
had to do it again so anyone that
receiving restricted supply water from
the council supplies are required to
provide adequate
ear gap which is a separation to prevent
backbone from a privately owned water
storage tank entering into council water
supply network now we have um various
places around the around areas where
there are fillers filling stations up
so um
anyone that's wanting needing to use
that needs to be registered to do so the
fire fire brigade and the latter part of
that
but um so if you see anybody that's
actually been filling out there that is
not approved to do so then you do need
to perhaps let them know because um
it's it could be a a source of
infection going into our water supply
which is really important but we don't
have that happened
um council approved a 12 months permit
to extend the flamingos
scooters to continue their commercial
services in waimakariri district
covering a time from the 1st of may 2022
to the 30th of april
2023 and that will be up to 300 scooters
and it has approved an extension of a
permit
by additional 12 months for any selected
providers
so they've gone and i'm sorry i don't
have it just on pmd but i've gone
through a list of
um any injuries and things like that
have happened now there's been um
photos in that taken of
of these um scooters that have not been
parked correctly um and
the the um
group the people that are concerned the
flamingos actually
um
find out who
they know who's the last person that's
part of them and so they go and contact
them and just tell them that you know
they've got to
advise them they need to be doing this
properly and if they know if they
continue not to do that then um they
they can't be better again so
that's makes me feel a little bit
happier about that um
that that people can't just uh
willy-nilly um abuse that um privilege
um now on monday nikki and i am going
with a group of
the working group for uh
housing with social
social and affordable housing we're
going off down to brisbane west
facility
in woolston and we're just going to go
and have a look at that facility just to
see
if
it would fit into our thinking for our
waimakariri area
um
and
just
their long-term road safety person kathy
graham has resigned from her position to
take up a role at
new zealand transport and her last day
unfortunately is friday the 8th
you mentioned about grant burn as well
which um
you know i take my head off to that that
you know but he's done such a great job
i really appreciate it
hey um but also another one that's been
a very long standing person and that
you know he's been 28 years
um
working uh you know for for the council
um and
he's just been such a an incredible man
and it's just nothing a problem for him
to go at any old time of the day and
night if there was a an issue eroding
issue and go and sort that out it's just
people like that um
really you know you take your hat off to
you because he was he's such a dedicated
man and i really appreciate everything
that he has done he's been working with
schools he's done the signage role for
for the district to grow
he's worked with lee's valley
maintenance there emergency event
response
um as she bought ashley bridge the old
bridge monica gold bridge
through the floods and then he's just
done so much work and it's just been he
truly is a very was a very dedicated
person just like to acknowledge that
very much so now just another thing that
you may be interested in for the
community in recreation
um in the library they've got various
things that are happening and there's
another one fiction addiction and you
can join this um
on facebook and you get
so many books to read and um
and it's it's a real sort of a group a
facebook group
and you'll find details on it um each
month they choose a book and then they
come back and and um make a comment
about it and they're all available from
the carpe box and renewal libraries so
and the other one is um
there's another one with languages other
than english that you can now is
available on borrow
box
and there's another one first for the
month
is connecting women's history months and
um check out these books that are
available
on this um
on
the facebook so if you need to know
anymore just go to
the library's libraries
and find a bit more information about it
so um
oh another thing that's also happening
too is that
there's a group of people that are going
to be looking at um looking at the
community christmas dinners again
there's a planning going on there now
and thomas you probably know we've been
about it do you
okay right well it's a
group of them from
the various areas and knox is one of
them
so ox and carpe ring you're in various
community organizations so they're just
starting to look at perhaps ways of of
helping those people that are that don't
have any family to go to and um
maybe
this christmas
cheer maybe maybe i'll be done this year
hopefully without covert
um now the last thing that might be
interesting for you also is from the um
libraries is sally o'donnell
o'connell sorry from our local heritage
coordinators continues her virtual
heritage tour featuring streets and road
signs across the district every saturday
morning
this social media team posts saturday's
street names a virtual
heritage tour on our facebook pages this
last week was the one that featured
information on points's road in custom
horrible
the street was named after stephen
edward points who was
first to lease the education reserve
land between house and wood wood fields
tram and oxford and points road
so it's every saturday morning they put
that on if you're interested and so plus
also they would like to know some
history as well about other roads in our
area
so that's me thank you
wendy how do we know if people taking
water out of the
[Music]
council system are
approved to do so
yes that well
those are there are some that are
approved as contractors that are
approved and to take i mean they'll have
to pay for what they take earlier but
then but there's also some that are um
just doing it and they're trying to stop
that because of the
they could contaminate the drinking
water which is
what this is all about
but we can't actually tell anybody that
whether they're well i think you'd need
to let the the staff know on that
thank
can i just ask a question please
can i ask a question of wendy
um i i understood um that the people who
have got approved actually had keys
to actually unlock it so how can people
but some of them
some of them surely are not locked
some of them aren't so well they're
meant to be yeah
yeah so that they just they've just
just highlighted it because it's
actually very important that we
that um
or whether they're using it
i don't i don't know how it works surely
i know that they they do have a lot to
to get in there but there's some that
are actually abusing the system
thank you
i've got a question as well
um
what's to stop people just using the
fire hydrant zone
well they shouldn't be really
well if you've got a fire hydrant key
you get from christchurch you could
easily come out here and
use that file use the fire hydrant to
fill up a tank or something i would have
thought so
yeah i don't know it just seems like a
lot of money to put those stations in
when you can still use a hydrogen
if they've got a key then they know
the rules and regulations about
and and they also have to have the
equipment so that they will not
contaminate the water and that's where
the fire brigade and those registered
contractors have the right equipment
that they want to contaminate back from
backflow and cause contamination because
that's very important
and the the um the rulings for for the
water is going to get even tougher so
just we're just trying to just track
down those that are that are abusing the
system that's all thank you thank you
baby
all right nikki
all right
um
wendy's probably talked about a few
things that are on my list
and
all i can say is in the last month it's
been a very busy month but as you can
see by the fact that i am wearing my
glasses for this entire time there's
been an awful lot of zooming going on
um
yeah probably the key words for this
last month are zooms and reform there's
been a lot of work on on
the many reform um programs that are
going through government right now
um just starting at the beginning of
last month on the fourth um attended the
rural and provincial
sector conference
and the main topics at that were the the
three major reforms that are going
through for three waters future for
local government and the resource
management
reforms
we also heard from the new water
regulator tomata oreo
and a particular interest to that
of that um to the board is that there
are 75 000 unregistered water suppliers
now caught in the new regulatory regime
and
basically what makes you a water
supplier is if you're
excuse me
as if you're supplying water to more
than one household so there's going to
be a lot of people out there that that
won't realize that are now going to be
caught up with with this
regulation they will have four years to
register and then for the three years to
meet the requirements of the water
services act 2021
but um
you know that's something that's going
to be a big step change for
small providers
you know if you have
if you've got a farm and you
um have a few farmhouses on that on that
farm that you supply from abor
or if you are in one of the sort of
older subdivisions out this way i know
amanda leeway for instance i know
somebody who um supplies
several
of the surrounding lifestyle blocks from
a bore on their property so people like
that are actually going to get caught up
in this and
i do hope that they will
get out there with the
communications and and try to find out
who and where all these people are they
haven't quite figured out how they're
doing that yet um because it's going to
be a
something that people will need to
consider
also um
the tomato roi guy said that common
sense exemptions for places like
backcountry dog hats for instance um it
it's just a sensible thing for them to
just simply put post a boil water notice
because it's really not practical if
you're way out in the back blocks to um
you know put in a big new water system
and all of that so um it's good to know
that they they will have a measure of
common sense there um as far as chlorine
exemptions go yes they're possible for
some of our urban supplies but there's a
very high bar set
i know that our our council water
guys are are currently working on that
very thing and um
if they can't do it no one can i have
faith in them but it's it is something
that um
they're very much dealing with right now
um on the seventh i
um organized a meeting
with some kia hoka people
um myself the mayor and tracy um to
answer some questions about um procedure
timelines etc for the hookah plan change
um there's there's quite a lot of
interest
ongoing interest with that uh one thing
tracy i would probably just clarify to
you with um sarah's question is when
this comes to counsel for acceptance
they're not saying yes we're doing it
it's just gonna become a fatal complete
they're simply accepting the report
and and for it to go out to consultation
or sorry to notification
so um the council is not saying yes
we're doing this i know we're not doing
this they they can't really do that it's
just uh okay you've crossed your t's
you've dotted your eyes
you've filled the paperwork out and paid
the fee and you've answered all of our
questions so we'll put this out now for
notification and go through the next
part of the process so
um nothing is
is a done deal at this point i don't
know does that make sense to you tracy
you look like you're pouncing on the
unmute yeah yeah so so the report going
to council gives them the options to
adopt it as their own plan change
decline it or accept it and it goes to
notification so
we'll work as we always do through the
elements of each of those options in
relation to this application and then
council makes that decision and we move
forward on that basis
yes
and i would i would note that it's
probably highly unlikely that they would
adopt it as a public plan change so
just my two cents worth
um
on the ninth there was the
said special sector zoom which um
basically ljnz updated us on
government's um three waters proposal on
changes to ownership safeguards local
voice and accountability
but dare i say it
most people are still not very impressed
with it and you've probably read in the
papers that um it probably didn't go far
enough um certainly not for our
council's liking or our people but
that's where that's at um on the 10th i
attended the oxford community networking
forum mind you sorry i'll just preface
this these are all zooms
unless i say otherwise they're not
physical meetings there's there's a lot
of zooming going on
um the oxford community networking forum
is is really neat um
and new oxford folks i'm sure are quite
aware of this but
basically what that does is it just
brings together various community
service providers that have
representative representatives who are
working
with youth the elderly disabled mental
health migrants social sectors as well
as food banks the cab well-being north
canterbury oxford community trust
all of those things at the moment have
coveted impacts
and there's particular concern for youth
as well as um
you've all mentioned before the the
cutbacks and um to care and the
temporary closure of the oxford hospital
um in addition to what sarah said with
that um
the dhbs are actually one of the reasons
i think um what we're told was that
um
they wanted to keep it closed over the
peak of the wave but nobody in in six
weeks after that well you know that's
that's kind of how long is a piece of
string
but one one important thing to note is
that um i believe it's the first of july
dhbs will be no more and it's going to
be health new zealand and health news
and so therefore the dhbs cannot commit
to opening anything because it may not
be their their um
place to do so because they may not even
exist by that point and um it will be a
decision to be made by health new
zealand so that's kind of why we find
ourselves between this rock and a hard
place but
we definitely have all of the mayors in
the area um
all
joined together and in
working hard to ensure that these rural
hospitals which are the backbones of the
communities um don't get forgotten about
and close because they're very important
to our rural communities
um on the 11th
of march there was a gcp meeting at the
moment gcp is currently
focused on greater christchurch
strategic strategic transport planning
investment and that closely also relates
um to future mass rapid transit and
spatial planning it's all one big
kind of
stuck together
thing but
um there's an awful lot of strategy and
and whatnot that and facts and
figures and things to weigh up with that
so that's a huge project which we won't
see an answer to really anytime soon
um on the 14th was the
lgnz zone five and six conference once
again um focused on the reforms um three
waters rma and future for local
government and there's also been a new
one nema
which um which has been added
which uh nema is the um national
emergency management
association
and um
yeah so that's civil defense so you know
hey we need another reform excellent so
lgnz to their credit has requested that
the government please not introduce any
more for any further reforms terms
because we have more than enough to deal
with at this moment
um
yeah so
again that that reform theme running
through
um
picking through here landon water
committee on the 22nd
of interest we have added 10 new wells
to a study that we've been doing of
private wells
10 each in carlton and i'm sorry 10 and
carlton 10 and swannanoa to a study
which previously only included
um wells and cust and ayrton so that
makes a total of 39 because one of them
had to drop out or there would have been
an even 10 in there
but interestingly 67 percent of ayrton
89 percent at cost
30 percent at carleton and 40 percent as
swannanoa exceeded the required median
of half the math the maximum allowable
value
of 5.65 milligrams per liter of nitrate
nitrogen um as for as required in pc7 of
the land and water
as you know plan for private wells
um
yeah that
and and no correlation has been found
between increasing well depth and
decreasing nitrates so all i can say and
the reason i'm bringing this up is if
you are on a private well it is really
important that you get that checked
regularly at least once a year
nitrates have no smell they have no
taste they have no color but they do
have a health effect and there's no way
of knowing
whether you are in a
high nitrate area unless you get your
well checked and
your well could be one thing and then
just down the street could be something
else so
um yeah i just would really like to urge
people if you're on a private board to
please get it tested
um
moving right along passing over a few
things
on the first there was an extraordinary
council meeting where we voted to remove
vaccine pass requirements and mandates
in line with with government
recommendations so that is in play as of
this week
um there are no longer
vaccine passes or
vaccine mandates and council facilities
government has pretty much removed that
and just made sense
and regarding the council meeting um
just of note wendy's mentioned a few
things here but
uh we have
received the canterbury climate change
risk assessment and that's got some
some big implications to work through
and
we also have a
more
minor grade one just for the district
which can give us a little bit more um
localized information which um it's just
a draft and it needs to be looked
through right now but um
that would be quite useful for us to
really understand what we're looking at
and and start start working on on some
things
um
regarding the flamingo scooter trial
that just ended you know they've worked
through the community feedback
they've granted a new license they
they've kept by and large the
geo-fencing speed and parking
restrictions so they were already there
and wendy also mentioned about the
parking so
um
it was interesting i think out of the
oh gosh
30 000 plus rides that were done they
only received 61 complaints that's not
bad going
um and and they have have worked with
with people that had concerns
um if you see something that's not
properly parked
um chances are it's because it's been
moved after the fact
because the clock keeps ticking
on on your tab until you actually stop
your ride take a photo and send it in
and if it's not properly parked they
keep the tab going so obviously it gets
very expensive for you if you didn't
properly park your scooter so that's
kind of a bit of an incentive
and
but if you see one that's that's just
you know should where it shouldn't be or
what have you um you can contact
flamingo and they'll actually send one
of their staff out to move it and fix it
because it's their problem and they need
to to stay on top of that um and as
wendy said they they've also given them
a
new one-year license
and um we'll see how they go with that
just as for local issues um i've
received a few calls from concerned
elderly regarding home care
and obviously the
hospital situation which you've all
talked about
we've talked about the hookah plan
change
there's the interest is still quite high
and um tracy's updated you on that um
regarding the butcher's road bridge
which any of you that live down this end
of the ward um might know it washed out
in february
and that's really been much missed by
the community and it needs to be
replaced but in the meantime i've been
contacted by resident um
and actually quite quite a few residents
have reported difficulty with
cycling and walking on the alternative
mill mill road route to kaiapoi and
they've asked for
the feasibility for it to be made safe
for foot traffic to be explored
and which joanne has duly done she's a
rock star i'm excited
she's
hopefully found a way to um open it as
soon as possible um providing that
there's not further slumping or another
rainfall event occurring
and and and palms will follow um but she
seemed to think that she might have a um
a way to make it safe in the meantime
for to be open for um cyclists and
pedestrians you know open to foot
traffic so you know fingers crossed
because um that's an important link in
our area
and also i just like to follow up just
regarding that memo that we had at the
end of the meeting there um i
about the
change in green waste composting
um
i saw that and i thought oh
yeah i
i wasn't sure what to think about it so
um i contacted um
matt bacon because i know surely he was
at the meeting with um
that you guys had
um with all the the concerned
stakeholders and i thought right since
he's he's in that compliance area i i
wanted to know um
that it was fully compliant with its
resource consents and that there hadn't
been any recent complaints just to
ensure that we'd done our due diligence
and that
we wouldn't be exacerbating any tensions
in the community and i also drove out
there myself just to observe because i
thought oh you know i didn't see any
traffic out there didn't smell anything
didn't hear you know it was you know
there's nothing really notable but i i
just had to satisfy myself that that it
okay because i haven't heard anything
from locals i'm worried about it lately
so fingers crossed that means that they
have actually addressed all of those
issues
um so i was assured that that council
are um conducting six monthly minimum
visits to ensure compliance and the
latest was done in early february this
year
so you know all of these themes um i
welcome the opportunity to reduce our
emissions as well as support a local
business in the process so
um but yeah it's just something that i
wanted to check out myself really
are there any questions folks
um i can i'll send through my um
members exchange thing to you guys
and um if you have any further questions
on those because there's a lot of things
i didn't talk about because we don't
want to be here all night
so
um but yeah if you have any questions
just get in contact
doug
yes doug
can i just mention something i forgot to
mention yep
the
oxford hospital
when they closed it down um
temporarily closed it down
they actually didn't take into account
that the oxford hospital actually
does meals on wheels for the oxford
residents
so they they not contacted about it
because linda hurry is the chair of the
friends of the oxford hospital when she
spoke to them about it they just said oh
well you know we've got some businesses
to to prepare the meals
she said no no
they need specialized meals um
and
so then right from that
that discussion
they have now have we stated the meals
on wheels being
made from the oxford hospital so that's
um
a good thing from there but
what happens who knows but and it's
really sad you know there was a resident
there that has lived her whole life in
oxygen for 98 years and she's actually
had to be transferred out of oxford so
that's it's a real it's that's horrible
actually it really is so
we feel very much for the family over
there
okay
thank you indeed
right somebody remove that those reports
be accepted please
no don't need to
no need to doug
all right
we'll accept them anyway thank you
okay
consultation projects
migrant experiences and escapes we need
to do anything there
no
board funding update
balance of the discretionary grant at 4
387 unless what we granted tonight
and the general landscaping fund has
basically been taken care of apart from
300 i think
media items there are none questions
understand the orders there are none
urgent general business understanding
orders there's nothing
so the next meeting will be
monday the 4th of may
monday
wednesday sorry about that it's a
wednesday
is that the fourth or the sixth
the fourth it's the fourth the fourth
okay
that's him bm right thank you
there'd be no further business
i'll close the meeting
thank you
thank you doug
thank you all for attending
thanks very much all
stay safe out there
and stay away from the mealing's house
my son has it and i've tested negative
myself three times
but i have symptoms now and i'm just
like what the heck so i actually went
and got a pcr today
um just to be sure
i just i don't want to get anybody sick
with this
so um
but there's 100 students off that's what
in our school today oh really 100 yeah
honestly if you don't want covet away
from young people
fun bought at home that's how we got it
and
over half of them were away today
thanks for that
so now we're it's ripping on through but
just a note i did a wee scientific
experiment with the tests nikki so you
might want to follow this
i had two different type brands so i did
it on both brands and i did a nasal and
i did a throat i don't have a sore
throat at all
um mine's all in my nose and
the nasal swab at um
the the t-strip when it goes up was went
up to negative and it was only probably
about
after it had set a couple of minutes
later that there was a tiny
faint positive but i did uh the back of
my throat and as soon as it went up it
was positive
i know that they say to put it in the
back you through it first and then and
then your nose which obviously you want
to press
really fancy doing that both but um yeah
came up straight away but the the nasal
one's very faint
yeah it's interesting for sure
okay to try your throat against your
athens yeah well i just thought you know
what this is crazy i don't want to be
wrong i don't want to
[Music]
you